all right the battle of a critical race
theory in our public schools has become
a major flashpoint in one place in
particular ground zero
the virginia governor's race republican
glenn younkin is within punching
distance of clinton hatchetman terry
mcauliffe and his support for parents
involvement in their education is a big
reason why as we speak yunkin is holding
a rally in burke virginia it's just
wrapping up and it's highlighting
government abuse and the failure of the
public school system here is what he
said just a few moments ago
when i'm governor i will demand
and we will get it
the repeal of the law passed by
democrats that allow school districts to
cover up serious crimes
never again
will radical school boards be able to
hide
be able to hide criminals
in our schools
here now chris ruffo senior fellow at
the manhattan institute and the central
figure in exposing critical race theory
in every american institution always
good to talk to you chris you know
you've done such a great job of exposing
this issue and i think americans are
rightfully outraged the question is at
what level
will it impact the ballot box will it
impact school board elections in the
case of virginia
will it swing this gubernatorial race
well i think it's uh time will tell it's
a very difficult uh political political
landscape because as you know virginia
is really now a deep blue state uh but
what i think that glenn yonkin is seeing
and we're seeing with the great
tremendous crowds that are rallying to
his side is that critical race theory uh
is an issue that
that polarizes parents obviously
conservatives oppose it but also
independents and then about a quarter of
all democrats also oppose it in schools
so he's seeing a territory where he's
moving fairfax and loudoun county which
voted for joe biden by about a 30-point
margin on average that are now
supporting him by about a 10-point
margin on the issue of critical race
theory so you're seeing a huge 40-point
swing to his advantage that's why he's
making it the closing theme of his
campaign
it's too early to tell whether that will
be enough but his internal polling data
must suggest that there's hope and
there's certainly hope in
hundreds of thousands of parents all
over this country mobilizing to fight
crt you know chris i'm fascinated by how
passionate people are about this issue
in my estimation rightfully so you know
i was talking the other night and a
mother came up to me and this was in a
social gathering but all she wanted to
talk about was this toxic ideology that
had made its way into her children's
school and chris i'm telling you beyond
passionate she didn't want to hear from
me about masks or even plexiglas which
she didn't want either she wanted to
talk about the poisoning of her
children's mind so i'm fascinated to see
like you pointed out a blue state here
because terry mcauliffe is also drawing
the line on education saying parents
should get out of the way parents should
not be manipulating what their children
learn i'm just so passionate i'm so
fascinated to see what this passion does
for
political implications
yeah i mean i think that this fight is
really not even about critical race
theory or no critical race theory
there's something that's much deeper
that i think motivates people like
you're talking about it's really a
question of who controls public
institutions in our democracy in our
society and our constitutional republic
is it going to be the bureaucrats and
diversity commissars and teachers and
unions or is it going to be as glenn
younkin is proposing to returning power
and authority to parents to voters and
to families and i think that really is
the key division do you want to empower
the people or do you want to empower the
permanent bureaucracy
and that's the national fight that we're
seeing uh playing out on this small
scale i certainly hope that that the
american people still have the instinct
for self-rule and self-government and i
hope that's what prevails in virginia
hey chris
you've not just been reporting on this
you've been leading the fight against
the spread of this this toxin okay so i
want to ask you this because this is
what this mother asked me what can we do
you know do you do you talk to the
school leader and i said the problem is
it's a ground-up problem at this point
it's teachers as well it's an ideology
taught in schools so in your estimation
as quickly as you can how is this
overcome
it's overcome through two things first
we have to just get it out of schools we
have to ban it and abolish it but in the
long term what we need to do is give
every parent in this country a right to
exit failing institutions no child
should be trapped in a failing public
school that violates his sense of
conscience that violates the values of
the parents every parent should take
those education dollars anywhere that
they wish school choice will liberate
people it will empower people and it
will actually depolarize some of these
national fights that we've seen hey like
like we learned and what we've known all
along vote with your free freedom is the
answer give people the power of choice
all right chris always great to talk to
you thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else